think is the most expansive user of
presidential power never went that far
and so I think that is really an
unprecedented effect that President
Obama will leave on the Constitution
that will have ripple effects going
forward because think about what would
happen if the shoe were on the other
foot suppose President Ted Cruz comes
into office he could say I want there to
be a 20 percent flat tax if Congress
doesn't do it then I'm just not gonna
prosecute anyone who doesn't pay their
taxes above 20% of you you're the 34
percent bracket and you don't pay it you
just pay 20 percent that's okay okay by
me right I think about what presidents
can do they're essentially gonna have
power to just rewrite the law into their
preferred US code even if Congress won't
pass it just by I'm not gonna force that
one I'm gonna force that one he could
enforce not he just for it's almost the
exact opposite of what the criminal laws
want so I think it's a I think in the
immigration area President Obama has
gone really so far out on a limb that
someone like me who's a great supporter
presidential power I can't go that far
with it well he didn't really issue an
executive order he just told his
Secretary of Homeland Security not to
deport people yeah yeah yeah you know
executive he used executive power but he
didn't write it out in a formal order an
issue it to be criticized yeah he said
he just recently told this the person
this cabinet secretary to cut cut down
on removals and so the number of
removals has dropped tremendous actually
well in his early years in office
President Obama had removed more aliens
from the country than any president ever
had before because Congress is pouring
more resources into it now those have
dropped enormous Lee and he's basically
also said the people who could be
removed you're safe we're not going to
come after you and there's two big
groups
Dakka Dakka and DAPA that the one group
is the children who were brought by
parents and what did they know they're
three years old and they're brought
across the border so and then the other
are the parents come here illegally and
have a child so now the parents are
illegal and the child's America yes
these are millions and millions of
people I mean there's a hard it's hard
to get a firm count but it sounds like
there might be
10 to 12 illegal aliens in the country
and this is a huge proportion of them
you know millions of millions of them
fall into these two categories the
problem is that the statutes written by
Congress
don't make any exceptions for either
class of people I you know I wish that
they're the people in both classes were
allowed to stay but through a process
that's been set out by Congress it's not
the president's job to decide who gets
to stay in the country and who doesn't
so six years ago when I was talking to
you about crisis in command we were just
about the year into the Obama
administration and I ended it by saying
oh so what are you gonna be writing
about Obama ten years from now and so I
it's not ten years at six so but you
were pretty president at that time I was
I'm so pleased you said well I'm really
concerned about his expansion of
domestic power I didn't you know he's
given a lot of his executive power and
foreign national security to the courts
I don't like that because at that time
they were talking talking about trying
Gitmo cases yeah in New York City
well if he's done even more that by
turning over for example electronic
surveillance and its approval over to
the courts I thought what I what worried
me was that to me in crisis in command
the point of the presidency was to act
vigorously and decisively and with speed
in the face of foreign threats in the
face of things like Congress and
legislators could not anticipate that's
why you would have a president that very
purpose is not important for domestic
affairs because their Congress can write
things the states are there you can
write laws to anticipate for a true
circus and things arise you can rewrite
the laws there's no big harm and acting
deliberately and slowly that's why you
use a legislature rather than one person
to run domestic affairs to me the story
now at the end of the amid bomb
administration when we last talked about
use it the original framework the
framers set up has kind of been turned
upside down under this administration
think we're in foreign affairs you've
seen the president withdraw even more
in the vigorous use of his
constitutional powers for leading the
country
he's deferring to courts he's deferring
to Congress with the decision not to go
into Syria
he's even deferring to international
agencies and the UN when he can but in
domestic affairs he's using all that
vigorousness and power that our framers
wanted the president to have her
national security he's using it on
domestic matters and his administration
is pursuing all these little people
where common sense should take care of
matters but he would rather have a you
know a permanent large regulatory state
take care of it I don't know though and
this may be the question as like how
that ever gets turned around because it
seems inexorable John you that is your
next book come back thanks i profit
small p six years thank you thank you
when I tune into it on the weekends
usually its authors sharing up their new
releases watching the nonfiction authors
on book TV is the best television for
serious readers on c-span they can have
a longer conversation and delve into
their subject book TV weekends they
bring you author after author after
author that spotlight the work of
fascinating people
I love book TV and I'm a c-span fans
[Applause]
thank you
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
u.s. Institute of Peace my name is Nancy
lindborg I'm the president of US IP and
I am absolutely delighted to welcome
here this afternoon for her first visit
to u.s. IP mrs. Bush we're very happy to
have you here and I also want to welcome
ambassador Moe [ __ ] from F Islamic
Republic of Afghanistan and mrs. Moki
delighted to have you here with us and
we have many other guests here in the
room thank you for joining us thank you
for coming this afternoon and for those
of you who are new to us IP we are an
independent National Institute founded
by Congress thirty years ago and
dedicated to the proposition that peace
is possible peace is practical and peace
is essential for US and international
security and we pursue a vision of a
world without violent conflict by
working in conflict zones with partners
equipping them with tools with knowledge
and with training and there's probably
no place where u.s. IP teams have spent
more time than in Afghanistan working
with civil society and government
partners to help make peace possible so
we're delighted to have today a panel
discussion to discuss exactly who are
some of the powerful women helping to
make peace possible in Afghanistan and I
have the distinct privilege of
introducing our panelists and our
moderator let me note that we will have
uh sure 'he's coming down the aisle to
collect your question cards for
questions after opening remarks if you
have a question please write down your
name your affiliation along with your
question on the card and we will make
sure that gets onstage so first let me
welcome mrs. Laura Bush former First
Lady of the United States she has long
been an advocate for expanding the
rights and the opportunities of women in
Afghanistan she's traveled to more than
76
countries enter including two historic
solo trips to Afghanistan and today as
the chair of the Women's Initiative at
the George W Bush Institute mrs. Bush
continues her work on global healthcare
innovation empowering women in emerging
democracies education reform and in
supporting the men and women who have
served in America's military we also
have with us today MS Meena share Zoe
who's a gender activist with more than
25 years of experience in economic
development and advocacy and Miss chair
zoe has extensive experience in
capacity-building and NGO development in
Afghanistan she's worked with the Afghan
Civil Service Commission and government
counterparts to increase women's
participation in government and
currently she serves as kamon --ax
Afghanistan based senior gender advisor
and is also featured in the wonderful
new book that we're here to celebrate by
mrs. Bush finally I'm delighted to
introduce mr. Stephen Hadley who
currently serves as the chair of u.s.
ip's Board of Directors as our wise
counsel and champion previously Steve
was the assistant to the president at
the national security affairs for four
years to then president george w bush
and from january 2001 to 2005 he was
assistant to the president and deputy
security adviser please join me in
giving a very warm welcome to our three
wonderful guests
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're delighted that all of
you can be with us and of course mrs.
Bush we are delighted to have you here
at the u.s. Institute of Peace and
delighted with your new book which is a
third series of and a collection of
wonderful stories and if you haven't
read it you really need to do so it's a
it's a terrific book what we're going to
do this afternoon is we're going to have
a conversation among mrs. Bush Mina and
myself for about 25 minutes or so and
then we're going to have a question and
answer period from you there are cards
that have been distributed please write
your questions on the cards pass them to
the aisles and there are we runners
coming down and getting them and passing
up to to me and we will try to get
through as many questions as we can will
then at the end turn to our our
panelists if you will and ask for any
closing comments and then we will we'll
adjourn promptly at at five o'clock so
again we're delighted that you're all
with us here for this wonderful event I
want to start this Bush with you if I
might you have a long history of being a
real advocate and champion for Afghan
women you were the first first lady to
deliver the presidential radio address
in November of 2001 and you spoke about
the plight challenges and and the
strength of Afghan women at that time
why is this such a cause for you of all
the things you could take on his first
lady as a cause why had was Afghan women
so important to you during your tenure
as first lady well right after September
11th when the spotlight turned on
Afghanistan American women including
myself has saw women who were
marginalized who were left out and the
very idea of a government that would
forbid half of its population from being
educated was shocking to Americans
American men and women
but a lot of people started calling me
to say I want to do something what can I
do to help and one of my best friends
from Houston called and said I used to
be so glad I wasn't in your shoes but
she said now wish I were I'm jealous
because you can do something and I can't
so right then we formed the u.s. Afghan
Women's Council and many American women
thought of various projects to to
support our sisters in Afghanistan and
that was really the beginning of my
interest in Afghanistan and in the women
there so all the years that we lived at
the White House and since I've stayed in
contact with many women that I've met
through the u.s. Afghan Women's Council
are met on my trips to Afghanistan I
wanted to write about him and you said
you wanted to write about them why this
book in in this way by the way if you
haven't seen it it has a forward from
mrs. Bush it's a wonderful real precis
of the tribulations of Afghanistan over
the last 25 years and wonderfully
written but why this book in this
particular way well it's called voices
of Hope and these are the stories of
women in Afghanistan and because their
voices were silenced I thought it was
important for to for all of us to hear
what they had to say besides that I
think the things have changed since
September 11th and things have changed
since that first time I visited
Afghanistan and I wanted people to know
that so I think this is a great way for
all of us to learn not only about each
of these women and one man one brave man
included to his stories his story but
also for us to learn more about the
history of Afghanistan I think we think
we know it all but their lives really
show the history of the last say 40
years of Afghanistan starting with for
many of them when the Soviets came in in
1979 and at that point some of these
women's immigrated
to Pakistan with their families some of
them ended up in the United States after
that but nearly all of them went back
after September 11th when they could go
back some lived there the whole time
through the years of the Soviet
occupation and then the years of the
Taliban in her cell there but I think I
wanted to tell their stories I wanted
Americans to hear their stories and I'm
thrilled I had this opportunity to tell
their stories with this book you know
you're one of the people in that book
you were born in Afghanistan came to the
United States spent most of your young
adult life in the United States until
9/11 which was traumatic for all of us
and so September 11 2001 you decided to
go back to Afghanistan tell us about
your decision to return to Afghanistan
and what you've been doing there and
your life there now that you have
returned in first Hill and why you were
in Afghanistan when was it when the
Soviets came in that yes I was in there
yes well first of all I want to thank
you and I'm very privileged to be here
on the stage with you mrs. Bush mr.
Hadleigh and I want to thank u.s. IP as
always to putting together such a
dynamic events and thanking everybody to
be a part of this who are here today I
was young had just graduated graduated
from high school Tohono High School in
Kabul and my father was a diplomat and
we were in Czechoslovakia he was an
ambassador at that time and it just the
we heard that the Russians took over
which was a shock and it came in in such
a shock that at first we didn't know you
know like okay they invaded the country
I was so young I didn't know the meaning
of it because of honest on it I like I
was raised in the golden ages you know
we didn't think of war I had never seen
a gun before or a tank or anything else
so to me it was like okay
somebody invaded and they will leave and
we will go back so we slowly immigrated
to the United States even my father had
the attitude that after three years we
will go back in the American ambassador
in Germany gave my father he was going
to give him citizenship green card
everything he said no no no no I'm not
gonna do that I'm going back in three
years so to make a long story short we
ended up staying for 25 years the
September 11th happened and when
September 11 happened of course my
father was one of the first people that
went to Havana Stan and he was the
deputy political foreign minister so I
saw the opportunity because a lot of
people were telling me don't go don't go
it's dangerous but deep inside all these
25 years I had such a passion to go back
and I always thought of the Afghan
people being there and suffering and I
always thought of having I mean thankful
and grateful for having all the
opportunities that I had in the United
States so how could I reach them and so
there was three of us three women one
was in Carmel - one wasn't in may in
fact that I lived in California so in
the Bay Area so the three of us decided
to start doing fundraising for the
Afghan women and we did fundraisings
before - because I used to do a lot of
fundraising and raise two thousand three
thousand dollars and send into the camps
the best I can do but this time it was
different the fundraising was like the
doors had opened so it's time to go now
time to go and give time to go and help
and take people's hands and whatever the
darkness has been in the past let's
overcome that so that's why I've always
wanted to go back that until September
11th I couldn't because of the war and
the Taliban and
was going on but after that I decided to
go back yes and what was it like when
you went back what was your first
reactions what was the in the
environment after 2001 and then tell us
a little bit about the environment now I
think being raised in the golden days
during the golden days of one Sun and
then being I'm really grateful for
living in America and to be honest with
you I cherished my life here because
America I gave me security peace
serenity education opportunities
everything and I went there actually to
be honest with you for three weeks
because I had two daughters I have two
two daughters and they were going to
college at that time so I said I'm going
for three or four weeks and I'll be back
which I've never returned and so when I
went back one thing that I saw that
triggered my heart in my mind at the
same time because when I landed they
took me the driver and my cousin they
took me to the American Embassy to
register for security reasons being an
American citizen you had to register so
I got out of the car and everything was
done on the street at that time so it
was a bit of time so I went ahead and
started signing the papers and talking
to the soldiers and and I turned around
this was actually March 14th when I
landed there so I turned around I saw
this ten year old boy or nine year old
boy in a raggedy clothes barefoot and it
was kind of chilly and he was polishing
my cousin's shoes for a dollar I just
saw that and I totally freaked out right
there and because I started thinking how
I was raised when I was 10 years old my
niece's my daughters my family my
parents my friends kids when they're 10
years old they're in another world
they're not even when they grow older as
we asked him to polish our shoes they
never have polish my shoes even now but
that broke my heart right there so what
I did the next thing I did was after a
week after studying everything I went to
my I called my daughter's I said look
there are people here I have been around
there are girls that haven't been to
school there your age they can't even
write their name so I know you need me
I'm Your Mother
I'll always be there for you but do you
mind if I can stay here for a few years
and help and take care of these girls
and guide them in a system in whatever
way I can so they were so supportive and
I always see them I said no no you just
wanted to get rid of a nagging mom but
they said no we knew your passion we
heard you on the phone and we when we
have time we will come and help you so
I'm really appreciative that yes
otherwise I couldn't have been there and
a word about the situation now the
situation now has changed as we all know
we see through the newspapers I just
came back on Wednesday things have
changed and I've honest not drastically
if you look at it from 14 15 years ago
when you look at women empowerment
education health clinics hospitals the
judiciary system I mean everything is
not a hundred percent perfect but at
least the seeds have been planted there
let's put it this way the only thing
that's really a barrier to development
of any country or anything you do in
life is security their insecurity in
corruption two things like for example
violation against women I'll give you an
example of that first of all the there
is justice system in Afghanistan we have
a lot of good laws but there is no way
of enforcing it
and forcing it in the mean because of
corruptions get in and the way so what I
saw this time I was there for three
months I had I went again for three
weeks I ended up for three months so the
security situation has really
deteriorated and I know a lot of
businesses are closing a lot of people
are becoming unemployed so this kind of
situation adds to the insecurity as well
because when something happens when
something goes wrong you don't know it
was the taller that was - it was the
teeth it was the person who was hungry
you don't know who did it yeah so right
now that's where things are the security
situation but even though let's put it
this way
the security situation has deteriorated
but we keep pushing things we don't stop
thank you miss Bush you went to
Afghanistan in 2005 then again 2006 2008
can you talk a little bit about those
trips what you learned some of the
insights you had and perhaps some of the
women that you met during those trips
some of whom probably show up in here in
your book now and once when I went to
Bamiyan province and met the female
governor there and Bamiyan is the
province that had the two huge towering
sixth century buddhas that were carved
into niches in the mountain wall and I
knew what they look like from
photographs but by the time I went
they'd been destroyed and they were just
rubble at the bottom of these two huge
niches that had been there since the 6th
century but then destroyed by the
Taliban so there was this contrast
between the ancient civilization of
Afghanistan with these old Buddhist that
had been destroyed and then the the idea
that there was a female governor which
was the newer thing newer since
September 11th and I remember coming to
see her and what that was like and how
thrilled I was to be there and
I see her but then also this big symbol
of them of the destruction of the
ancient palimony really of Afghanistan
and did you meet some of the women at
that time that are in your book now I
met most of the women that are in the
book here in the US through various
things here Rossi and John who's here
let's see worthy there she is over there
and others whose stories are mean
obviously whose story is here I've read
when I've been on the book to her I've
read from Mina's the story the the what
she just told us the story of seeing the
little boy without shoes polishing the
shoes of someone else and have that
struck her in that picture stayed in her
mind and led her to want to uh spend so
much time there
so I've formed a lot of friendships with
women in Afghanistan and it's been
really I mean oh and some of them are in
new year some of the women in this book
I don't know but they are there are a
few of them here as well today you know
I'd like to go back to something you
started there's a lot of intermittent
press coverage here about Afghanistan
most of it bad you know security is
getting bad
Taliban are on the move and all the rest
and I think we don't often appreciate
how far the country has come and you
started to talk a little bit about that
could you say a little bit more about
what has really been accomplished here
in the last fourteen years or so like I
said earlier we have accomplished a lot
for 15 years ago we didn't have girls
going to school we didn't have clinics
for women we didn't have women ministers
we didn't have women in Parliament so I
can go on and on especially business
women women advocates the first year
when I was there let me let me let me
explain it to you this way when I first
went there I was looking for women too
that they're doing the handicraft in the
carpet weaving and all that
so I was looking for them all over the
place and you couldn't find them even in
burkas on the streets so I ran into this
mullah and I kept asking I just want to
see like 10 or 15 women that I could
work with and I could talk to and maybe
I could teach them some stairs if our
economic empowerment purposes he said
okay why don't you come on a Friday and
I will go ahead and show you the 15 and
20 women so you can work with them I
kind of didn't tell anybody where I was
going because I know if I tell my dad I
was going to this mosque he will send
ten guards with me or he won't let me go
so I was afraid but I did go with my
friends and to be honest with you I
walked into that mosque I had I saw
hundreds hundreds of women with burka
sitting there and they were back was
facing me when I entered and I stood
there I said you got to be kidding me
what am I gonna do with this hundreds
and hundreds of women so I stood there I
pretty much give them a message and talk
to them saying that I'm here to help
I'm here to empower them I'm so that
they are not needy they are not a
charity case anymore because I'm very
against big becoming a charity case
where they have young women so you have
to learn you have to work and earn your
money in order to raise your children
help your family and husband and
everyone so I lived there that's what
encouraged me to put together an NGO so
I put together an NGO for widows
especially and I registered over 10,000
women and in six years then we did an
assessment and to be honest in 10,000
women I had only 56 literate women
that's only high school I'm talking high
school which is some of them were eighth
grade ninth grade so the dirac are
literate and so this is what happened
and then I was able to get you know
funds from the
institutions donors and I did the
capacity-building and tailoring sewing
and English and literacy and computer
classes as we started expanding but
looking today you see a lot of Afghan
women out there this is what I'm trying
to compare at that one that time you
know you couldn't find anybody but now
you find hundreds and thousands of women
out there even in the provinces or in
Kabul and on media for example you see
them on television the journalists the
teachers I mean they're all over the
place so it's not that difficult to find
out young women now thank God one of the
things that mrs. Bush's forward there
are some very nice statistics showing
the progress on health and education one
that struck me I think at teenage girls
now 36% literacy 37% of the teachers in
Afghanistan are now women so really
remarkable progress and mrs. Bush I know
one of the things that the at the
Institute and the Presidential Library
you have been very instrumental in the
women's initiative at the bush Institute
continuing the work you started as first
lady what kinds of activities are going
on in that project within the bush
Institute well at the bush Institute
we've had four classes of women fellow
fellowships to from Egypt and to from
Tunisia and we began with those two
countries because they were the first
and most active in the Arab Spring
countries that we bring women all from
the same country for a fellowship so
that when they go home they have each
other and they can introduce each other
to their colleagues and their families
and their friends and thereby broaden
their networks there's an SMU professor
who did research that shows that your
network is as important as your
education level to your success
and in societies where women are inside
more they didn't have the chance to
build the kind of networks that we as
American women do so we've had now for
classes to Egyptian class listen to
Tunisian of fellows and we'll do another
group this year of Egyptian fellows and
our ideas just to continue to focus on
these two so when they go home they
really have a broad network now with the
two groups and and and everybody else
they've introduced each other too so
that's one of the things that we're
working on as part of our Women's
Initiative we have a Women's Health
Initiative we in Africa we've added the
testing and treatment for cervical
cancer which is the leading cause of
cancer death among African women to the
PEPFAR platform the AIDS platform that
was set up when George was president the
President's Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief that's all across Africa now it's
really helped Africans build a health
infrastructure with PEPFAR money
treating aids to start with but now
adding the testing and treatment for
cervical cancer to to that so that's our
global health initiative which of course
is focused on women as well we have a
first lady's initiative we began with
conferences in Africa with African first
lady's to talk about how they can use
their roles in their countries while
their husbands are a head of state to
work on issues that are important to
them we've tried to match them with NGOs
or corporations that are active in their
countries and then talked about good
governance the one one African woman
said well I know the government paid for
your clothes and we said no they didn't
melanda there happened to be there chi
immediately said no they did not
thinking about missus clinton but but we
do talk about good governance in the
ways that first ladies can help and now
we've broadened that to more than just
African first ladies we have the first
lady's initiative with first ladies from
all around the world what else
piers charity she's the head of our
Women's Initiative Pittman Bush
Institute oh and then of course that USF
in Women's Council we just which we just
came from a meeting of here
so African I mean Afghan first ladies
are part of our projects as well working
with Afghan women and that's obvious I
mean that's what this book is and that's
why I would wear here today and one of
the things I thought is nice is it
really is a I was honored had the
privilege of sitting in on the meeting
today it is a bipartisan effort I mean
this is one area where Republicans and
Democrats have worked together and I
thought it was interesting that former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton wrote
a nice blurb on the back of the day and
I think it continues to be a bipartisan
effort here by the American people by in
the Congress and that's a wonderful
thing mean I'd like to go back to you if
I might and just ask you what is the
sort of the frame of mind the spirit of
Afghan women today what are they
thinking about what are their their
hopes particularly the the young women
who have who have seen such change in
their lives what's you know when you
talk to them what's their frame of mind
today what are their hopes what are
their fears the frame of mind of Afghan
women like I said earlier it has changed
through the time of the first of the
passport that in the past 14 years
they're not the same of young woman that
they were 14 years ago they have come a
long way they are they have learned
their rights in every way and there's
learning I'm not saying if the whole
country knows all the women they know
their rights but they're still right or
learn learning and the other thing is
they have learned how to add advocate
and their spirit is high all the time
one thing I found about young women no
matter if it was the golden ages of one
asan or the bad days or it doesn't
matter where they are how they are how
bad it is they have a high spirit
they're very brave they're very
courageous and they have this strong
inner hope that it keeps them going all
the time I have seen women that has
really been through a lot of hardship
and it just surprises me that how she
comes to work the next day with a smile
on her face and still you don't know
what she has been through and it's that
mask that she wears I call it it's that
mask that she wears in order to look
strong to move on and to in convinced
her children and her family it's okay
that everything would be fine and of
course just like everybody else
Afghan women are like they like the
other women in the end the world we're
not any different than the Afghan women
it is just the differences what kind of
opportunities are given to them and what
kind of opportunities are given to us
that's the difference and the insecurity
also plays a major role for them so
Afghan women and overall they're in high
spirits and their dream is to be just
like everybody else
a normal mother normal wife normal
citizen and they just want to live just
like everybody else even though like I
said things are really getting rough
these days but I don't know if you have
seen the news and all that how they're
pushing on the 500 case they're going
there
locating there all over the place just
one example
so nothing stops them we're going to
turn shortly to some questions from the
audience I have lots of good questions
we'll try to get through as many of them
we can I'd like to have a question
really for each and and both of you
before we do that
one is sort of unbalanced are you
hopeful for the future of Afghanistan
and what can we the international
community and we Americans do to try to
sustain the gains that have been made
Bush could I start with you and I'm
hopeful partly because what Mina's said
because I do know the spirits are in the
strength of Afghan women and I think
that comes across in the book and in the
stories of the women that are
interviewed in the book so that makes me
hopeful I also think that the whole
international community we in the United
States as well as the whole
international community needs to
continue to do whatever we can to
support women in Afghanistan and support
the Afghan people we need to help them
build an economy so people can have jobs
so people can make money so that people
can be become independent and those are
the things that we need to continue to
do but I also was heartened that
President Obama chose to keep our troops
there I think we need to keep the troops
there we need to make sure that they add
that Afghanistan has the security to be
able to build the stability to form
their government and continue to work on
what they're working on I know mrs.
Ghani the new first lady of Afghanistan
is very effective she's a member of our
u.s. Afghan women's council that met
earlier today and sent a message to us
she's hoping to build a women's
university with women professors so that
still when the traditional fathers don't
want their daughters to go to university
because of going with men or having men
professors that there'd be an option for
women and I think that's a good way that
Americans could support her and that is
to
try to help in that way as she builds
this women's university but obviously
the most important thing is the security
and our troops can help on that Mina
same question to you are you hopeful and
what should we do
and I agree because without security
Security's a number thing number one
thing without security you cannot move
forward
everything starts collapsing around you
and and we don't want the international
community to leave as well we have
started something as the international
community and we have to continue and
make it really solidified you know make
it happen and make it show the world
that you know we were there not with a
15 or 20 or 30 years and it happened you
just don't want to leave a country in
chaos when it's in chaos and that shows
the failure on the international
community so we have to continue what
we're doing and we have to really pour
more money into development in the
military I'm sorry it's just if if we
have capable people and if people have
food on a table and they have jobs why
would you need military this is a
question for me because I'm not a
politician when I'm an activist so
that's it comes to me all the time
so for me first comes the development
yes we do have to train the police to a
limit we do have to trained our military
because of our neighbors but if you have
good citizens and if you don't have
hungry citizens who can be bought by
your neighbors or by any politician or
anybody I mean you will have a stable
country but unfortunately for the past
14 15 years yes a lot of money has been
poured but it hasn't really been poured
into the real real development side of
it it has been a lot into the military
and police which has not been very
effective either so even now
money a lot of the money has been
allocated to the defense and military
but I think if we could just add to that
and for you know add more money to
development to develop people to give
them jobs to create jobs the other thing
that has happened with the trainings we
train but we don't follow we can train
all we want there should be a follow-up
program maybe up to a year not short
term but long term yeah we can do the
trainings a month two months or then
everybody leaves okay so many women were
trained and so many men and okay big
pictures and done but we have to follow
up if this person really found their job
if this dream if this training was
effective if it wasn't effective then
what should we do to make it effective
because we have already spent a lot of
money and we want to see the result
that's successful to everybody to the
donor to the Afghan people to everyone
so that's where I'm coming from I don't
want anybody to leave but to get more
money at it to the development side of
it good food is a security issue as well
yes in fact they think that one of the
reasons the Taliban and and the that was
that little boys were put in these
madrasahs but their parents put him
there because they were hungry and they
got fed so their food ends up being a
security issue as well I wanted been
reading this one part of the book they'd
open I think that's what what we're
talking right about right now in the
rest of the world we live in a very
fast-paced life we want everything to
happen in front of our eyes we don't
think about the future we don't invest
in the future unfortunately and that
needs to change I'm sure other nations
have gone through this societal change
probably hundreds of years ago
I think it'll happen in Afghanistan we
just have to be patient and not give up
because once you give up you have to
start from scratch all over again yeah
this talking about the the non-security
side and an issue that's very dear to
the heart of us IP this is a question
from Barbara from PAE for both of you
the US government is implementing the
largest rule of law program of its kind
in the world in Afghanistan what should
be its focus in the next five to ten
years particularly as it pertains to
women and girls Meena do you want to
take a shot at that one like I mentioned
earlier the rule of law we have laws we
have many laws needs to be enforced we
have to learn how to enforce laws and
how to use laws I remember I did have a
in my NGO for two months I had a
training for women law lawyers this was
probably ten years ago and it was very
interesting for me to find out that one
of the lawyers she was being abused by
her husband at home but then she would
get out and go to court and try to
defend everybody else so when I found
that out I sat her down I said if you
cannot defend yourself how can you
defend others she started crying she
goes even when I'm standing there trying
to defend others I'm not making it
because the judges that are there they
have already been paid or they are
stronger than me or my are the one who's
across the table from me the other judge
the opponent I mean the the lawyer is
stronger than me and I'm always always
get defeated this is why I need this
training we need to really focus on
women in judges in the attorneys
starting from the university that's
where we need to start working maybe the
second or third year a third year of the
law university to start kind of
practicing with them and
locating for them and teaching them how
to defend themselves first in the house
if you cannot defend yourself within
your home within your own circle then
you cannot defend yourself outside or
defend anybody else and I also know
lawyers and attorneys in Afghanistan
that are women the hill let me tell you
they were very tough but there is just a
few there are in that many and I think
we need to really tap and focus on the
younger generation that are going to be
the next lawyers because the lawyers
that are there from the past maybe 45 or
50 at that age I'm not trying to
discriminate or anything it's really
hard for them to change their way of
work and their way of implementation and
attitude and all but one thing we can
focus on is the younger generation and
teach them to really be the real lawyer
to be in that court to win to go with an
attitude that I can win so that's what I
think
good job next question yeah they're all
hard one of the ones there's sort of two
that are related one comes from Marissa
answer of Georgetown University and is a
question for Mina I'd like to first ask
this one Edie for really again for both
of you this is from Lalit occasi of the
pazzo Afghan News I probably
mispronounced that I apologize there's
been an on-and-off-again talks of peace
talks with the Taliban
on-again-off-again uncertain how it will
go do the women's Bush that you work
with and some of the women in the book
that you know and have talked to and
mean it for you as well are there fears
about the peace process and fears of a
peace agreement between the Afghan
in the Taliban for what it will mean for
women for what it will mean for the
progress that women have achieved since
2001 will you go make peace with the
Taliban I thought the latest I read is
they left of the table the Taliban if
they come back or do you know is anybody
know here they they have left the
Taliban have left the table recently I
think in the last couple days Andrew
Wilder and Scott cancer Hekmatyar who's
one of the folks has indicated that he
is willing to participate in the Afghan
peace process query whether that will
have an impact on the Taliban so it's I
think it's still on again off again but
the question is really are there some
anxieties of course there is a lot of
anxiety especially among women through
this peace process and if you look at
the whole picture the overall picture if
you have in the peace council a peace
council that was created years ago when
you have 70 men and five women or six
women how do you arrive at peace because
there was five or six women that were
selected they also cater to whatever
that 65 or 70 men are saying so women
are in minority and women are scared of
course they are they're an anxiety and I
think again they're fighting this in
every way they can and they are so they
don't get sacrificed you know during the
peace process so they give you know they
like during the taller bond times how
where women were secluded from
everything and they don't want that to
happen again because we have gained so
much for the past 14 years and there is
no way we will sacrifice that no way I
doesn't matter what I mean I could I
could tell you this because I come from
I
always have these gatherings these women
and when they come from these meetings
you should see their faces say over my
dead body
that was there that's how they speak
there is no way I'm gonna give up what
I've gained in 14 years
and politicians I'm sorry would
sacrifice my right to the tallip in
order to bring peace that is not peace
at the end of the day we are isolating
half of the population so I don't think
it will happen it is just an ongoing
thing there is a lot more involved to it
than the women it is what our neighbor
country is asking for they're asking for
a lot of things that Afghan people are
not going to give up so that's my
understanding
the Peace Council we've talked a lot
about women and girls and the important
role they have in the Afghan Society and
the important role now in peace building
one of the things that came up and the
meeting earlier today was related to
this question it's unsigned as you will
how important do you think efforts are
to reach men and boys in addition to
women and girls if we are to change the
culture and values of the society well
that has to be done for sure reach men
and boys I said earlier in the u.s.
Afghan Women's Council meeting that one
of my friends said to me I don't know
why you're working with the women it's
the men that need the work and there are
efforts and we did hear that in the
meeting earlier to work with men to tell
our boys especially to talk about peace
in conflict resolution and all of those
other things but I think what happened
is these boys weren't parented the ones
that are grown up now that are the
terrorists or the Taliban they didn't
have parents who taught him how to be
men and I've taught him how to you know
mother and dad that taught him how to
live instead they were sent to these
madrasahs and they
were brainwashed and they were not
taught how to get along with people and
that's what a family a good family does
a mother and a father and that has teach
all the children the boys and the girls
how to get along with other people and
and that other people's lives matter too
I agree with you mrs. Bush but there is
one thing and being in Afghanistan for
the past 14 years that I've recognized
yes we first have to work with the boys
with the men because if the men and the
boys are brought up pro-women
then we don't have to exactly any
problems and in the meantime what has a
war done to these men we have to look at
it this way and I cannot blame them most
of the time it's because that boy that
was born 30 years ago he was born during
the war
and you have to be protective of the
women and children and the girls during
the war so he was then the Taliban came
so that was like an icing on the cake
for this whole thing the mentality so
that boy has been raised with that type
of a mentality protect your woman don't
show your woman don't show the girl and
right now we are going through a social
change and it's going to take time it's
going to take probably another
generation or two for men to come out
and say yeah it's okay for really in a
very normal way that we're doing it here
you know it's okay if my daughter goes
to work it's okay if my daughter goes to
the movies it's okay if my daughter does
this or that or my wife right now you
see these challenges it's because of the
war the war has brainwashed the men in
Afghanistan and that generation is still
there and it's going to be there for
another maybe thirty years but it's
take a long time maybe two or three
generations so you could really see the
change this is a related question from
Mira I Ozzy who's a student at George
Mason University
it's a little long but it's a good one
as a first-generation Afghan American
I've been raised to learn how to balance
my Afghan heritage with my Western
surroundings given that Afghanistan has
a patriarchal structured society what
clashes or conflicts have you seen arise
as a result of the resistance to women's
equality that some may view as a Western
idea rather than an Afghan idea and how
have you seen balance created with
tradition and this so-called Western
idea of women's equality and empowerment
it's beginning to be like jeopardy the
first thing that's very common it's the
word gender there were gender in
Afghanistan I mean in the gender is
equality empowerment between men and
women and all of that I mean we know
what it means it includes male and
female but when you talk about gender
and Ivana son they all talk about what
they all think women they think it's a
Western thing to have equal rights of
women while to be honest with you in
Islam we do have equal rights for women
there all rights for women there are
good rights for women and what happened
in the beginning when we all first went
everybody went in without doing their
homework everybody brought in the
Western ideas and unloaded in
Afghanistan without thinking what is the
culture what is the acceptance of all of
these things how would people take this
so when we started all these gender
trainings
it didn't go very well so you had to
rename these things and and really let
people know what it really means and as
a napkin American when I've been there
I've watched they would perceive you as
an Afghan no problem but later in the
day you know they would say okay you're
here I know you're helping me I know you
did this for me but you know what you
have a passport you're going to leave
you have that option and I always tell
them yes I have that option but I'm here
no matter what and and that's one of the
reasons these are all the perceptions
because Afghan people they really have
to trust you
and I don't blame them for not trusting
anybody because to be honest everybody
has come in and invaded and left and
ruined and took so they don't trust
anybody and it has to do with the war
and the way they have been treated and
now for the past 14 years yes thanks to
international community thanks to all
the donors they have been there they
have pushed issues for women like for
example it politically to be in the
Senate to be in the parliament to be in
the government I mean the foreign
ministers so it has been the foreign
push as well not only the government but
still they have these doubts until you
overcome those doubts with the Western
issues they will doubt the Western
issues anything you put forward they
will think twice whether okay whether it
comes from Germany that comes from Egypt
where it comes from America it doesn't
matter as long as it's from a foreign
entity they think twice they think they
just don't want to go for anything
anymore
they'll think twice and say yes or no
yeah thank you very much we regrettably
have come to the end of our time I want
to thank all those who submitted
questions and my apologies to those who
submitted questions we